all right China's flying balloons over
our country so let's watch it we've got
some breaking news to get to and explain
the northern U.S according to three
officials familiar with this a
spokesperson for the Pentagon calls it a
high altitude surveillance balloon
saying they're monitoring it closely
Courtney cubey has been on this in court
so Montana Parts of Alaska Canada and
potentially over some U.S military sites
do I have that right yeah so it was last
fight if China is
um sending enormous spy balloons
satellite balloons over North and South
America just out in plain sight first of
all the obvious disrespect that they
have no regard for our president right
now and they know that he is completely
volless and he'll never do anything yeah
but what are they doing in secret if
they're that that's a reason right
that's what I was going to say I feel
like there's there must have been a
better way to do this like you could
have rented out a room on a on a tall
story building and put up your your
little set up there yeah but they
already have everything on us we give it
to them so when you do when people play
these little games like hey use this app
and see what you're going to look like
as an old person or something you look
like as a baby they're collecting
they're they're combing your phone
collecting all your data they know
everything they need to know about us
and our Behavior oh so they know exactly
what you like with Tick Tock this was a
test this was a test to see if our
president has any cojones yeah no I
failed I agree it was a test I don't
know why but um I feel like this is just
such a stupid situation it just seems
like such clown World [__] that I wonder
what like the real motives behind it are
well they want they're gearing up to to
attack Taiwan and you know the US is
like don't you do it just the same as
the U.S told you know the uh Putin don't
you don't you invade Ukraine or we're
gonna do bad things and we've done you
know we give it Ukraine nobody has any
respect for us right now yeah it's
ridiculous so that's what this is that
we know of about around Billings Montana
Air Force Base which critically keep
some of their icbms their Minuteman 3
icbms that being said it as far as we
know it was no it was not over that base
U.S officials were still extremely
concerned so concerned Holly that
yesterday Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin while traveling in the
Philippines how do you know it's from
China too I don't know I don't know how
they knew that like is there the Chinese
flag on it the big symbol on it maybe
China owned up to it being a meeting of
his senior leaders in the middle of the
night his time including chairman of the
joint Chief General Mark milley other
DOD leaders the head of North com Nora
and NORAD who was here in DC at the time
convened them to discuss this they
looked at the flight track the track of
this how did how did it only make
mainstream news when it was over
Billings Montana it had to go over the
whole Pacific Ocean coming straight at
us we could see the trajectory did it
come from the Pacific Ocean wherever it
came from it didn't just wasn't it
wasn't inflated over Billings Montana it
flew from China this is such clown [__]
this is so stupid but it's serious but
it's very serious super serious here at
a band where they believed it was going
and then they assessed its ability to
actually gather any intelligence they
looked at options including taking it
down out of the sky ultimately they came
to the to the decision uh to the
agreement that if they were to shoot
this thing out of the sky it would
create a debris field that would put
people and assets on the ground in
Montana potentially
U.S borders what is it 12 miles out is
our international border 12 miles out I
don't know we have Radars for all this
[__] too none of this adds up I don't
know they were so serious about this
potential that when there was a window
or while it was this this balloon was
over Montana they actually scrambled U.S
aircraft air Fighters including f-22s
with the potential that they could take
this thing out she's not asking any
questions
none of the obvious questions like why
wait until it was over Billings you're
going to tell me that we were that on
that they didn't notice until then what
was are they doing drinking all of them
what was going on they didn't take they
didn't shoot this surveillance balloon
down but they are taking action on the
ground U.S U.S Senior defense official
said that if it this balloon continues
to fly and it goes near any sensitive
places they will they they keep open the
option to shoot it down and they'll move
things around on the ground to make sure
they can't actually gather any sense
they also said that if it's going over
this place they said initially that they
didn't want to shoot it down to hurt
people it's like bro what are the odds
you pop a balloon in the sky and it
lands on someone's head well it's not
like a little Pennywise balloon it's
yeah I get that but it's like it's a big
piece of equipment kind of like a um can
you not just wait until it's over like a
field I think it's similar to a blimp so
there's a lot of metal it's a lot of
well they're going to wait until it gets
into a sensitive area what when it's
like over the suburbs of Chicago going
for the Sears Tower that's a better time
to shoot it down what the hell look at
this lame journalist on the left not
asking one single question they're all
just oh wow wow wow really this is
incredible reporting court and as you
know it's really significant for a lot
of the reasons that you've laid out it
also feels like now that it is sort of
now that we know about it
um there is a major not just military
component here but like a geopolitical
diplomatic component right like there's
gonna you would think that
you think there's a geopolitical
diplomatic component yeah freaking smart
this lady oh God and so many people are
watching this thinking she's smart send
a warning to China that says absolutely
cut this out so always
communicated with China both here in DC
and in Beijing that they're aware of
this balloon and and they have they have
sent some sort of a message but I spoke
with the senior defense official who
declined to say exactly what that
message was or whether the Chinese
acknowledged that this was their balloon
all that we know so far is the U.S the
Pentagon is confident that this does
belong to the People's Republic of China
and apparently they're mad
yeah China's mad we shot it down now
it's like what do you expect well they
have to say they're mad I mean you could
you imagine the Chinese war room when
they're like well how do we always think
was gonna happen if we invade Taiwan
let's do something to like see what the
US does let's just pull some [__] like
what other ideas did they did they
strike down before they agreed see how
the media reacts yeah no they're the
media reacts they don't care how the
media reacts let's see how the Pentagon
reacts how the White House reacts yeah
there's there's ulterior motives and
what the news says like what what do you
what info are they getting from a
balloon that they don't already have
again it's it I don't I it's it's less
about surveillance that's what I'm
saying than about testing us [__] suss
for real you know I just want to know
what else they what other ideas they had
on the at that brain because they had a
meeting and they were like what they
have a goal in mind so the goal was to
test the US to see how much they'll do
they brainstormed a bunch of different
ideas and then they were like all right
balloon over Montana which is a giant
blimp over but you know and then see how
the media reacts let's see what the
president does like the president
actually makes the decisions but it's
interesting it's very interesting and um
if anybody else out there has any ideas
throw them in the comments of what what
else what ideas did they shoot down
before they settled on the on the Spy
balloon I can't think like an evil
empire so I don't I'm I'm not coming up
with anything right now no it is it is
funny to think though that it was
literally a group of guys sitting in a
room thinking of something that would
achieve their goal and they had other
ideas what I don't know I don't know
what their their other ideas were I mean
I wouldn't think of flying a balloon
over this is like legit I feel like this
is like a Mike Myers comedy in real life
okay so we gotta worry about that now we
got to worry about what's next and the
Fallout from this and how China how
embolden they are now to do whatever the
hell they want what are you gonna do
ramping up to world war three here we go
it'll be the half yachts and the Have
Nots and down here we got still people
fighting over their pronouns oh yeah
we're [__] it's over all right thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
at sunnyfast I'm posting a lot of cool
stuff there in my story for you to check
out and I'll see you later
[Music]